Glanz und Brecht
[Musik]
schönen guten Morgen sichert ja hallo
Markus was machst du gerade woran
arbeitest du ach ich schreibe gerade an
meiner
philosophie-geschichte weiter vierter
Band lang und umfangreich und immer
schwierigere Sachen über wen denkst du
gerade nach ich denke gerade über ein
ganz unglücklichen Menschen nach
antoniogrammschi Antonio gramschi war
ein italienischer Politiker und
Journalist 20er Jahre und der dann für
zehn Jahre ins Gefängnis geworfen wurde
von Mussolini und dort tausende von
Seiten Folge kritzelt hat und dessen
dessen wichtigste Theorie darin besteht
subtil über macht nachzudenken von dem
Stand das Bild der Begriff Hegemonie ja
also wie wie muss man herrschen damit
man tatsächlich mächtig ist
und wovon hängt eigentlich macht am Ende
eigentlich ab oder macht Verfall oder
machtgewinnung das ist hochinteressant
muss überlegen wenn man die Bedingungen
sich vorstellt unter den Gramm Ski da in
italienischen Gefängnissen gilt hat und
der einzige Grund warum das irgendwann
mal aus dem Gefängnis geschmuggelt
werden konnte war dass das keine ernst
genommen hat weil die Werther das nicht
verstanden haben und gedacht habe ich er
schreibt den ganzen Tag nur Quatsch ja
interessant ja erst spannend eine tolle
tragische Geschichte meines Wissens nie
vor filmt und macht macht es ja wenn man
mal anfängt darüber nachzudenken ist ja
wahnsinnig interessant ne ich meine
Macht ist ja am Ende auch das andere
glauben dass du mächtig bist absolut
also es gibt ja zwei Arten von macht das
ist einmal die Macht die du innerhalb
deiner eigenen Peer Group hast ja ja
also die Macht die du hast dadurch dass
du viele Unterstützer hast und die Macht
die du hast gegenüber deinem Gegner
das sind ja zwei verschiedene Dinge
völlig verschiedene Dinge her ja genau
und das eine ist du musst führend sein
vor deinen eigenen Leuten ja und mächtig
gegenüber den anderen
und das hat er sehr schön analysiert
wir hatten gerade
bei uns in der Sendung war total
interessant die mit riglukowski kennst
du vielleicht Science-Fiction Autor drei
Millionen Bücher verkauft allein von
Metro 2033 es ist eine ganze Reihe und
jetzt hat er ein neues Buch gemacht das
kommt demnächst Geschichten aus der
Heimat ein russischer Schriftsteller
Moskau geboren und sehr interessanter
junger Mann ist um knapp 40 und der war
mal als Journalist relativ nah an Putin
dran und hat hat gesagt die Macht dieses
Menschen gründet sich ausschließlich auf
der Macht des Fernsehens ausschließlich
er sagt dieser Mann ist klein und hat
Haarausfall und es gibt klare Regeln du
darfst sie nie von hinten Filmen weil
dann würdest Du noch mehr Haarausfall
sehen und die Kamera muss immer auf
einer bestimmten Position auf einem
bestimmten Niveau sein bitte nicht zu
hoch das System bei denen sie es Ansagen
können bei russischen Kamerateams und so
weiter wird das genauso angesagt und er
sagt er war völlig verwundert als auch
unser studiobetreten hat dass da nicht
Menschen mit Kalaschnikow stehen weil
Fernsehen für jemanden wie Putin ein so
wichtiges Instrument der macht ist dass
es mit allen Mitteln verteidigt wird und
deswegen betrittst du ein ein Moskauer
Fernsehstudio nur indem du irgendwie
vorbei gehst an Menschen mit
Kalaschnikow das fand ich sehr
interessant und sagte die Macht von
Putin Gründe sich ausschließlich auf
diesem Medium und der hat das auch sehr
früh erkannt beschreibt das in einem
interessanten Text wo er sagt der hat
das ganz früh gemerkt als er nämlich
verstanden hat
dass er der gerade eben noch der der
Junge völlig unbekannte KGB-Offizier aus
Petersburg war praktisch über Nacht in
diesem riesigen reich mit elf Zeitzonen
weltberühmt war sozusagen ja in Russland
weltberühmt und da hat der verstanden
welche macht eigentlich Fernsehen hat
interessant Wetter wahrscheinlich von
Leuten wie balosconi oder so gelernt hat
die das schon vorher exerziert haben
genau und und Leute wie Trump wiederum
haben das auch vom Berlusconi sich an ja
wobei das Interessante ist das Trump ja
seine macht ja auch auf Twitter
aufgebaut hat genau
soweit ich weiß nicht ich würde mal
schätzen dass die betriebsko für ihn
twittert wahrscheinlich das ist der Typ
mit dieser mit dieser teuren Uhr die
irgendwann mal vielleicht
vier Millionen Dollar Uhr ich wusste gar
nicht dass es so teure Uhren überhaupt
gibt wusste ich auch nicht aber der der
verdient glaube ich im Jahr 120.000
Dollar oder so und hat dann seine sehr
junge Freundin geheiratet und es kam die
Frage raus so schon mal erzählt ja genau
und er sagt es war ein Geschenk seiner
sehr jungen Freundin die hat sie ihm zur
Hochzeit zur Hochzeit überreicht ja
Wahnsinn womit beschäftigst du dich denn
gerade du ich ich
viel Arbeit viel Sendung und nebenbei
aber etwas worauf ich mich sehr freue
bin jetzt am 15 glaube ich Samstag
nächsten Samstag in der Eishalle hier in
Hamburg weil wir einen großen
multivisionsvortrag zeigen Grönland
Arktis und so und das ist so schön weil
ich viel auch Computer sitze gerade und
dann sehe ich dieses Polarlicht
dann höre ich diese Huskys heulen und
dann taucht man so Weg in so eine völlig
andere Welt und es ist so großartig so
ein Gedanken auf Reisen zu gehen ich mag
das so gerne und ich ich habe gerade
gemerkt wie sehr mir
richtiges Wetter und Kälte und Sturm wie
sehr mir das fehlt und ich ich finde das
immer schön für einen Moment so komplett
abzutauchen dass das das ist immer so
irre du bist inmitten einer Großstadt
irgendwo und dann geht das Licht aus und
dann kommt so der der Wind und dann
hörst du ein paar Grünländer sprechen
und dann siehst du so ein paar Gesichter
in schwarz-weiß und so und es dauert 30
Sekunden und dann bist du völlig
eingetaucht in dieser Welt das ist
wunderbar da freue ich mich drauf dass
das bereite ich gerade vorher weil wir
so ein paar Termine im Norden haben und
immer wieder mal gefragt werden ob wir
das mal zeigen ja genau
Richard ich sozusagen auftauchen und
rein in die in die harte Realität ich
habe heute morgen mit Paul runter einmal
telefoniert
den ich sehr schätze weil er ja diesen
ganzen Krieg schon seit 2014 sehr
intensiv begleitet und zwar so nah dran
wie möglich so nah dran und ich habe ihn
gefragt wie es denn so geht und sagt es
war auch gerade sehr sehr gefährlich
weil die Ukraine einen kleinen Gruppen
irgendwie vordringend und der ärgert
sich über russische Propaganda und er
ärgert sich im Moment aber noch mehr
über ukrainische Propaganda es gab diese
Szenen diese diese Schachteln mit diesen
ganzen Goldzähnen und daraus hat dann
das ukrainische Verteidigungsministerium
gemacht da hat ein mini-ausschwitz so
haben sie es bezeichnet stattgefunden
guckt euch das an vor den Augen der
Weltöffentlichkeit die ganze Welt hat
auch darüber berichtet so nach dem Motto
das sind die die Goldzähne von
ermordeten Ukrainern und er hat sich auf
die Suche macht und ist in einem Dorf
fündig geworden hat den Zahnarzt
gefunden der all diese Goldzähne
irgendwann mal ausgebaut hat weil er
sagte nee die habe ich ausgebaut die
haben sie geklaut als sie mein Haus
eingedrungen sind russischer Soldaten
und das sind das sind meine Goldzähne
und die die habe ich einfach
rausgenommen weil die meinen Patienten
weh getan haben und nichts mehr tauchen
und das ist so ein gutes Beispiel für
Journalismus
und genau dafür und einer hingeht und
sagt pass auf die Geschichte glaube ich
euch nicht und und auch ehrlich gesagt
als jemand der sehr stark immer für die
Ukraine gesprochen hat trotzdem hingeht
und sagt das hinterfrage ich jetzt mal
die Geschichte kaufe ich euch nicht ab
ja das ist der der Anspruch den man
haben muss ne also man Herzen vollkommen
parteiisch sein
aber in der Rolle die man spielt ist man
der Wahrheit verpflichtet ja genau und
in dem Zusammenhang fragt er mich auch
gerade was ich so mache sagt ich bin
gerade auf dem Weg ins Studio um um mit
dir zu sprechen da sagte Mensch wie
geht's denn Richard Precht und ich sagte
ich glaube ganz gut aber ich ich stelle
mir vor war eine turbulente Woche für
dich oder ja also das ging ja eigentlich
enormes Gewitter gleich los und ja und
es war ja im Grunde genommen so dass ich
das bestätigt hat was wir im Buch
geschrieben haben
dass unsere Leitmedien nicht so richtig
trainiert darin sind mit Kritik
umzugehen und das natürlich als erstes
in so einer Zeit die Verletzten und die
wütenden Gesicht zu Wort melden und ich
glaube das ist genauso passiert wie wir
das in der Einleitung des Buches
prophezeit haben
ja also ich ich fand das war auf jeden
Fall eine interessante Sendung es war
nicht die beste Sendung ich glaube man
könnte zu dem Thema eine viel bessere
Sendung machen und ich glaube wir
sollten auch noch mal einen zweiten Teil
machen gerne eine bessere Sendung gehabt
also ich habe das als als rumgezanke vor
Publikum empfunden und das hätte ich
sehr sehr gerne vermieden ich meine wir
sind ja in die Sendung gegangen um über
die Thesen des Buches zu diskutieren
auch in der Hoffnung dass es ein
konstruktives Gespräch gibt und es war
halt schade dass das nicht möglich war
in Teilen fand ich also ich fand es in
Teilen sehr interessantes Gespräch ich
ich mochte das ich mochte auch diesen
Schlagabtausch ich mochte auch die die
faktensicherheit auch von jemandem wie
Robin Alexander zum Beispiel und fand es
auch dann interessant wie dieses
Scharmützel zwischen euch beiden
entstanden ist über die Flugverbotszone
und dachte darüber noch mal lange nach
weil du sagtest steht im Buch und
stellte sich dann heraus steht nicht im
Buch und ich habe dann gedacht warte mal
vielleicht hat der Richard das im Kopf
ja das Stimmrecht hat das sogar
geschrieben dass genau wir haben das aus
dem Kapitel damals rausgenommen weil um
den um den Kreis nicht zu weit zu machen
wir wollten ja eigentlich um den Kern
der der des offenen Briefes gehen und
deswegen haben wir das nachher wieder
rausgestrichen und tut mir natürlich
etwas passiert wenn man 280 Seiten
schreibt dass man sich da manchmal nicht
mehr daran erinnert dass man da
irgendwas rausgenommen hat oder nicht
ich meine so eine so eine Arbeit an dem
Buch das zu redigieren das sind ja fünf
bis zehn Korrekturläufe indem man noch
mal umstellen genau das und das muss man
halt sozusagen wenn man wohlwollend ist
dann besteht man das dem anderen auch zu
und wenn man destruktiv ist dann sagt
man guck mal alles wieder Quatsch und da
ist der Beleg dafür genau
aber weißt du was Richard ich habe sie
auch in der Sendung so gesagt ich habe
es auch schon in der Einleitung so
gesagt das ist ja kein Buch gegen
Journalismus im Gegenteil und es ist
auch kein Buch das sozusagen
Querdenkern besten Stoff liefert ein
keinster Weise und ich habe das Gefühl
jetzt wo sich der Pulver Dampf so ein
bisschen verzogen hat es setzt ein bei
mir schon lange und da auch noch mal
speziell so ein Nachdenken über das was
wir machen über die Frage was guter was
schlechter Journalismus ist und wie
wichtig es ist sozusagen alle Seiten
dann auch in angemessener Weise
abzubilden dieses Nachdenken setzt
gerade ein das ist ja das was wir uns
erhofft haben also wir schreiben ja ein
Buch in der Einleitung am Ende auch das
ist das Ziel also wir wollen und aus der
Angst heraus dass wir dass das Krisen
Dauerzustand werden und die Befürchtung
ist ja groß ich glaube die stabilste
Erwartung die man an die Zukunft haben
kann an die nahe Zukunft ist dass wir
immer wieder Krisen jetzt haben werden
also das einzig stabile ist die
Sicherheit von Krisen exakt und in einer
solchen Situation werden Gesellschaften
einem enormen Stresstest ausgesetzt und
da muss jedes Teilsystem einer
Gesellschaft muss ich fragen lassen ja
genau sind wir helfen wir dabei den den
Kit der Gesellschaft zusammenzuhalten
haben wir eine konstruktive Rolle in
diesem Spiel und aus so einer
Perspektive muss müssen sich viele
Menschen das fragen lassen und ein Teil
ist natürlich das Mediensystem und das
ist unser Anliegen dass wir hatten dass
wir gesagt haben wir wollen dass das
unsere Leitmedien hier einen
konstruktiven Beitrag machen und dass
sie nicht mit dazu beitragen neben
vielem anderen dass die Gesellschaft
auseinander fliegt weil diese Sorge habe
ich ganz ehrlich wir haben ja uns häufig
über die amerikanische Gesellschaft
unterhalten da sind ist als erstes die
Medienlandschaft gestorben oder hat sich
radikalisiert polarisiert und so weiter
muss man auch sagen die Amerikaner haben
natürlich auch schlechtere
Voraussetzungen gehabt sie haben keinen
öffentlich-rechtlichen Rundfunk gehabt
der in Deutschland natürlich vorbildlich
ist auch wenn ich mir das ein oder
andere kritisiert haben aber es ist
natürlich sehr stabil dass wir das haben
ja man kann das eine oder andere
aussetzen aber es ist gut dass man das
hat im Vergleich zu Ländern die sowas
nicht haben und wir haben auch eine
qualitätsfresse und bei uns geht es eben
darum dass wir diese Qualitätspresse
verteidigen aber eben auch gegen gewisse
Tendenzen wo wir denken darunter leidet
die nein und es ist doch auch wichtig
dass wir uns hinterfragen weißt du ich
mir ging es schon bei der ersten Lektüre
so und du weißt doch tauscht uns ja auch
häufig im Hintergrund über dieses Thema
aus
ich bin da jemand der der ja
gewisser Weise beide Seiten gut kennt
mir ist völlig bewusst dass wir selbst
wenn ich das so nicht will aber
natürlich mache ich Meinung aber ich bin
auch jemand der auf der anderen Seite
häufig erlebt dass über ihn Meinung
gemacht wird und und wenn man das beides
mal so erlebt wie man auch erlebt wie
brutal das sein kann wie unangenehm das
werden kann dann dann dann weiß man ein
bisschen einzuschätzen was da gerade
passiert ich hatte aber immer die
Haltung ich habe mich nie darüber
beklagt ich werde mich auch nie darüber
beklagen und ich finde es absolut
richtig dass man sich kritisch mit dem
was was ich tue was andere Leute ist man
sich kritisch damit auseinandersetzt
weil das nehme ich mir auch bei anderen
heraus und insofern darf ich da nicht
meckerig werden wenn es mir selbst
wieder fährt nein es ist das letzte also
ich beschwere mich überhaupt nicht über
die Reaktion ich wünsche mir nur im Sinn
unseres Anliegens das sozusagen die
Diskussion mal weniger emotional geführt
wird weniger personalisiert sondern das
werden aber so langsam in die
sachdebatte einsteigen können entfernen
wir das Rückkehr gestellt aber ich sag
mal so ich mochte das ne den Teil mochte
ich ja so dich mal so richtig unter
Feuer zu sehen und also argumentativ und
und den ein oder anderen Blick den nur
Kameras in Großaufnahme so einfangen
können das war das war von Highlight das
hat mir es hat mir gut gefallen und ich
habe ich sag mal so selten vier so
ausgeprägte Persönlichkeiten in einem
Studio
erleben
doch mal wie Talkshows früher aussah ich
weiß also das war ganz häufig kritisiert
dass in unseren Talkshows ja gewinnt
derjenige der am freundlichsten ist und
am besten gekleidet und am charmantesten
und so weiter und ganz anders als zum
Beispiel in französischen Talkshows ja
da wird sich ja angeschrien in einem
Ausmaß wie wir uns das gar nicht
vorstellen können und das war auch
früher bei Christiansen so da wurde sie
durcheinander gebrüllt und unsere
Talkshows sind ja immer sitzsamer
geworden das hat natürlich auch Vorteile
aber dadurch ist natürlich auch nicht
mehr so diese Dynamik drin und ich
glaube wenn man jetzt so die Highlights
der Talkshows der politischen Talkshows
aus den letzten zehn Jahren rausfischen
sollte dann hätte man es einfach
schwerer als wenn man die von früher
rausfischt genau ja wenn wir jetzt dazu
beigetragen haben ein weiteres Mal sagen
ja das können wir aber doch mal schön
nehmen dann war das am Ende vielleicht
das schlechteste nicht völlig allein der
Irre Blick von dir an an einer Stelle
als du Melanie einmal anguckst
unvergessen wirklich da dachte ich okay
jetzt kann ich aufhören weil besser
wird's nicht mehr Leute äh Richard weil
du gerade sagtest Risikogesellschaft das
ist ja genau der Punkt die die die diese
Risikogesellschaft über die sollten wir
jetzt mal reden über die Ängste mit dem
es plötzlich zu tun haben dieses
unkalkulierbare ich habe dieser Tage was
schönes gelesen von einem britischen
risikoforscher David Spiegelhalter
Spiegelhalter ich weiß nicht wie man dir
genau ausspricht der fragte mein Gott
was ist eigentlich mit euch deutschen
los und er sagt dann ihr solltet euch
eigentlich lieber statt euch vor
Atomkraft zu ängstigen lieber vor Pizza
ängstigen weil an Pizza und
Herz-Kreislauf-Erkrankungen sterben
deutlich mehr Menschen als anatomkraft
sowas kann natürlich nur an Engländer so
lässig aussprechen richtig wenn man das
bei uns ausgesprochen hätte hätte man
riesen Ärger hätte man riechen stelle
sich vor ein deutscher Politiker hätte
das gesagt ja ja nicht nicht auszudenken
aber es ist dieser herrliche britische
Humor aber es ist ein Thema ja das finde
ich ein spannendes Thema also wie
realistisch man Gefahren einschätzt und
wie man sich in Situationen verhält
indem man Gefahren gar nicht realistisch
einschätzen kann richtig also das erste
Thema ich hatte das auch in meinem Buch
über die Pflicht dass ich mal beim
Beispiel von Corona erklärt habe dass es
tatsächlich wesentlich gefährlicher ist
Corona als vieles wofür die Leute
deutlich mehr fürchten normalerweise
also die es gibt eine völlig irrationale
Angst vor Insektenstichen es gibt einen
noch irrationalere Angst vor
Haiangriffen oder vor Schlangen Bissen
in tropischen Ländern und so weiter die
also in der Statistik in überhaupt kein
Gewicht fallen ehrlich gesagt die Gefahr
durch einen Terroranschlag ums Leben zu
kommen bei uns ist auch ausgesprochen
gering und ganz viele andere Dinge
Verkehrsunfall ja natürlich sehr sehr
viel wahrscheinlicher und das was dein
Engländer da gerade erzählt hat
natürlich die größten Risiken denen wie
die wir normalerweise im Alltag haben ja
das ist Zucker das ist Salz das ist
Alkohol das ist Nikotin das sind die
größten Lebensrisiken die wir haben
pizza ist lecker aber mörderisch muss
man sagen tödlich auf die
[Gelächter]
dauert
das was mir in der Schule immer mein
Chemielehrer erklärt hat Zucker und Salz
sind tödlich es ist nur eine Frage der
Dosierung so ist es so ist es genauso
wie wir alle auch ein bisschen Jesus
sein können von Zeit zu Zeit weil wir
dann auch alle in der Lage sind über
Wasser zu laufen ist alles eine Frage
der richtigen Temperatur
genau aber jetzt um einmal kurz ernst zu
werden das was im Raum steht gerade und
das sagte Paul ronsheimer wollen auch
noch mal am Telefon
Ukrainisch offizielle viele gehen und
auch das Umfeld von silensky die gehen
davon aus dass ein Atomschlag
wahrscheinlicher geworden ist
und dieses ganze Thema Atomwaffen das
ist etwas das steht gerade im Raum und
es ist deswegen so
beängstigend weil wir eigentlich dachten
das haben wir hinter uns gelassen und
man muss ja auch sagen Atomwaffen haben
den Charakter von Krieg und vom Politik
ja grundlegend und für immer verändert
also es gibt ja sozusagen eine Zeit vor
Hiroshima und es gibt eine Zeit nach
Hiroshima
Atomwaffen haben den Einsatz erhöht ja
das Interessante ist nach Hiroshima ist
eigentlich folgendes passiert die die
beiden
nuklear Mächte die Russen hatten ja bald
darauf auch
Atombomben und Wasserstoffbomben die
haben sich nicht mehr direkt angegriffen
und das war ausgeschlossen dass es zum
Krieg kommt Kubakrise mal ausgenommen wo
es auch ganz ganz knapp war
aber ansonsten haben sie
Stellvertreterkriege geführt und der
Vietnamkrieg war so rein
Stellvertreterkrieg viele Kriegen in
Afrika waren solche Stellvertreterkriege
Auseinandersetzungen in Südamerika also
Diktatoren gegen kommunistische
Volksführer und so weiter waren solche
Auseinandersetzung man hat es also
vermieden dass man direkt aneinander
gerät ich glaube das war die ganz große
Folge der nuklearen Aufrüstung
ja und das erinnerst du dich es gab das
extra noch mal nachgesehen im
US-Wahlkampf 1964 gab es einen ganz ganz
berühmten Werbespot Linden wie Johnson
der berühmte Daisy Werbespot kennst du
den noch
geboren 1964 ja ja ich höre die
Melancholie in deiner Stimme das ist das
ist ein ein Spot der beginnt damit dass
ein kleines Mädchen
so ein Gänseblümchen zupft und und zählt
so wie Kinder das machen ne zupft das ab
und dieses Kind Daisy fängt an zu zählen
1 2 3 bis 10 und als sie dann bei zehn
angelangt ist
übernimmt plötzlich so eine so eine
bedrohliche so eine so eine männliche
sondern weißt du so eine Bleche Stimme
und zählt plötzlich rückwärts und aus
diesem harmlosen Zählvorgang wird
plötzlich ein fieser Countdown und du
ahnst was passiert die Stimme geht
runter bis auf Null und dann siehst du
den Atomblitz zucken über diesen
Fernsehbildschirm und dann kam Johnson
ins Bild und sagte darum geht's entweder
eine Welt zu schaffen in der alle Kinder
Gottes leben können oder in die
Finsternis einzutreten und dann weiter
wir müssen uns entweder lieben oder wir
müssen sterben das war nicht total
interessant weil das und das war quasi
wahlkampfspot das war wahlkampfsport
zwei Jahre nach der Kubakrise und es ist
total interessant ich meine wir alle
haben doch dieses make love not war ja
das liest du dann auf T-Shirts und so
weiter und ich dachte immer das ist so
eine Parole die sozusagen von der von
der linken Seite kommt ja
Hippie und so tut es ja auch aber selbst
zu einen hartgesottener Typ wie johnson
war offenbar auch dieser Meinung und hat
das auch ganz klipp und klar verstanden
und das war sozusagen interessant weil
danach
beginnt ja eine andere Phase in der
Geschichte der Menschheit danach beginnt
sozusagen der Nationalismus eher
unwichtiger zu werden weil uns klar ist
es ist egal hinter welchem Zaun du dich
versteckst hinter welchem Amerika du
dich versteckst hinter welchen Italien
du dich versteckst wenn es dazu kommt zu
einer echten nuklearen
Auseinandersetzung dann dann kannst du
dich nicht mehr verstecken dann liegt
alles in Schutt und Asche und auf eine
gewisse perverse Weise hat diese Logik
ja dazu geführt dass wir dann in der
Folge eigentlich eine lange lange Zeit
von sehr viel Frieden erlebt haben
zumindest in unserer ja in unserer
Region ne also wie gesagt das ist das
Zeitalter der der Stellvertreter Kriege
genau ja aber es ist wir haben danach
die lange stabile Friedenszeit Europa
gehabt genau ja das stimmt so und das
beängstigende für mich wenn man anfängt
mal so darüber nachzudenken ist genau
dieses Gefühl ist plötzlich wieder
zurück dieses Gefühl ist wieder das
gruseligste und das muss man auch sagen
unwahrscheinlichste was man sich hätte
vorstellen können wenn wir jetzt die
Welt einfach nur paar Jahre zurückdrehen
müssen sie ja nur ein Jahr zurücktreten
genau uns doch nicht vorstellen dass wir
jetzt in einer Welt leben wo ein
atomarer Schlag im Bereich des Denkbaren
liegt wir müssen ihnen ja nicht für
wahrscheinlich halten es reicht doch
schon völlig aus ja wenn er durchaus
denkbar ist
und wir wissen ja auch gar nicht was
dann in dem Fall passieren würde das ist
ja klar dass ich meine der Westen hat
auch klar gemacht es wird eine
entsprechende Antwort geben was auch
immer das ist das ist natürlich also ich
diese Angst dass wir auf einen
Pulverfass sitzen und dass wir keine
exit Strategie finden ich frage mich
immer damals bei der Kuba-Krise die
wurde dadurch beendet dass Christoph dem
Befehl zum beidrehen gegeben hat genau
die Russen haben in der allerletzten
Sekunde als accountdown schon fast
angefangen hat ja das ging ja damals
darum die Russen wollten auf Kuba
atomraketenstationieren gerichtet auf
die haben natürlich behauptet sie wollen
es nicht ja aber sie haben dann ihre
Schiffe losgeschickt um die da zu
stationieren weil sie am Kuba verbündet
waren konnten sie das und die kennen es
die kennen die Administration hat gesagt
wenn diese Schiffe nicht beidrehen
sondern wenn da die raketenstationiert
werden da gibt es den Dritten Weltkrieg
und ich glaube man hat da noch hinter
den Kulissen so ein Deal gefunden ich
glaube einen Teil war dass die
Amerikaner ihre Atomraketen aus der
Türkei abziehen sollten ich glaube das
spielt im Hintergrund eine Rolle und
nachdem es da quasi eine Zusage oder
sowas gab hat Christoph beigedreht
weil das war quasi Antwort darauf also
ihr habt Raketen an unserer Grenze und
dann schicken wir euch Raketen an eure
Grenze und das Spannende ist eben dass
es in allerletzter Sekunde geglückt ist
noch beizudrehen damals stand die Welt
wirklich am Rand eines Atomkriegs ganz
ganz nah das kann man so sagen ja und
ich frage mich jetzt bei dem was wir
jetzt haben wir stehen vielleicht gerade
noch nicht am Rand eines Atomkrieges
aber die Frage ist wie kämen wir ja wenn
das jetzt noch weitergeht aus der Nummer
raus also wer gibt den Befehl zum
beidrehen quasi ja oder wie sehr der
Deal aus dem man hinter den Kulissen
machen könnte um das zu verhindern das
ist schon ausgesprochen mulmig ja ist es
wobei wenn du noch mal ein Gedanken
weiter vorne ansetzt
wir wenn man sozusagen das Wort hört
wenn dann Olaf Scholz ich fand das
damals ehrlich gesagt das fand ich
wirklich nicht gut im Spiegel mal kurz
Atomkrieg zu Raunen ohne zu sagen was
das Teufel eigentlich wirklich bedeuten
würde dass das fand ich damals keine
gute Botschaft ich verstehe was einem
Hinterkopf hatte ich verstehe einfach
nicht die echtes ruckel gehabt der hatte
Angst dass er der Bundeskanzler ist der
Deutschland in einem Atomkrieg führt
also ich glaube dass er diese Angst
immer noch hat genau aber weißt du was
mein Punkt ist Richard und das ist
eigentlich ein interessanter Gedanke
finde ich wir denken immer wir können
sowas nicht abwenden und und wir sind
sowas einfach so so ausgeliefert und und
können uns eigentlich nicht mehr bewegen
so ein bisschen wie wie hier der
berühmte Soziologe Ulrich beckner in
Risikogesellschaft das finde ich so
beschrieben hat dass du eigentlich das
Gefühl hast du sitzt da so wie so ein
Kaninchen in der Schlange und irgendwann
macht es Kavum und und dann liegt alles
in Schutt und da schon du kannst nichts
dagegen tun und wir sind wahnsinnig
hilflos aber das Interessante ist doch
es sind genau zweimal diese Waffen zum
Einsatz gekommen
und danach hat doch die Menschheit
eigentlich gezeigt dass sie mit dieser
mit dieser Art von mörderischer Waffe
eigentlich umgehen kann also alle
Supermächte Amerikaner Russen Europäer
Chinesen die haben doch die Art und
Weise wie Politik gemacht wird in das
Pakistan noch genau wie Krieg geführt
wird
verändert also es wurde nicht mehr
versucht gewaltsam Grenzen zu verändern
es wurde nicht mehr einfach der Nachbar
überfallen es wurde deutlich weniger
Blut vergossen zumindest in in den
Ländern muss man sagen sprechen ja genau
in Europa nicht genau in Europa ja und
auch in den USA also ich will sagen wir
haben doch gezeigt dass wir eigentlich
damit umgehen können und jetzt sind wir
plötzlich wieder in so einem Punkt und
Albtraum zurückgebucht in die 60er Jahre
ja also mit einem Schlag ja wie mir ab
Scotty jetzt fängt wieder einer an so
mit dem Feuer zu spielen genau das
genau das und ich frage mich Richard das
ist ist dir ich wollte dir die Frage
stellen weil ich mich mal interessieren
würde ob dir das so klar war meine wir
alle und ich gehöre eindeutig dazu ich
hatte keine Ahnung davon wie sehr
eigentlich in den letzten Jahren
speziell mit Blick auf Russland und aber
auch die USA wieder ein unglaubliches
Wettrüsten eingesetzt hat ich habe immer
wieder diese spektakulären Bilder
gesehen von putinären welche
überschallraketen getestet haben
und so weiter genau aber eigentlich ist
dieses Wettrüsten so still und leise im
Hintergrund vonstatten gegangen und wir
alle haben uns und das muss man auch
selbstkritisch sagen auch journalistisch
wir haben uns nicht dafür interessiert
stimmt wir wollten das nicht wissen ja
stimmt war dir das klar ja wir wollten
das deswegen nicht wissen weil wir
gedacht haben es kommt sowieso nicht zum
direkten unmittelbaren Konflikt stimmt
war dir das war dir das klar hast du das
bewusst wahrgenommen nee habe ich nicht
also mir war klar dass die weiterhin an
ihren Waffentechniken Arbeiten ich habe
mich ja mit künstliche Intelligenz
beschäftigt mir ist klar was da alles so
in der Pipeline ist was da alles gemacht
werden soll das die Rüstungsindustrie ja
nicht kleiner geworden ist dass die
wehretats größer geworden sind ja in
fast allen Ländern genauso die ganz
wenigen Länder mal gucken wo die
Rüstungsausgaben geschrumpft sind die
Polen werden demnächst weit über 100
Milliarden in ihre Armee Investition ist
bewusstest du das nee das wusste ich
nicht weit über 100 Milliarden dagegen
ist das Sondervermögen der
bundesspirale weitergeht aber ich habe
das ja nie verbunden damit das ist jetzt
von der unmittelbaren Konfrontation
kommen würde
nee habe ich nicht und was ich im
Augenblick einfach wahnsinnig
interessant finde und das ist für mich
da würde ich auch gerne mit dir drüber
sprechen der Punkt wie schätzt man in
einer solchen Situation wo einer sagt
wir haben übrigens Atomwaffen wir können
ja auch einsetzen
wie schätzt man da realistisch das
Risiko ein und wie stimmt man sein
Verhalten darauf ein wenn ich eins über
den Krieg gelernt habe dann ist dass ich
nichts weiß und ich habe auch den
Eindruck dass es eigentlich kaum jemand
gibt der was weiß ich habe am Anfang du
ja glaube ich auch geglaubt dass die
militärische Stärke der Russen so groß
ist dass die Ukraine nur ganz kurz ich
wird verteidigen können ja das habe ich
auch ganz gefühlt genau das waren aber
viele Militärexperten die das gesagt
haben und hieß Russland zweitstärkste
Armee der Welt und so weiter also dann
wie soll sich ein Land wie die Ukraine
dagegen wehren so jetzt habe ich gelernt
ich lag da völlig falsch ich habe da auf
Experten gehört die offensichtlich keine
Ahnung hatten
und das gleiche ist natürlich auch jetzt
so der all die Dinge was geht da in
Kreml vor sich was geht da in Putins
Kopf vor sich wird die Ukraine
konventionell jetzt immer weiter
vorstoßen und tatsächlich die Gebiete
zurückerobern wird sie das nicht
Dinge die er überhaupt nicht wissen
überhaupt nicht einschätzen können was
gibt es eigentlich noch für Waffen außer
taktische Atomwaffen was ist denn
Chemiewaffen was mit Bio Waffen was ist
mit Laserwaffen ich kenne mich mit
Waffen nicht aus ja ich bin nicht Anton
Hofreiter der sich jetzt im letzten
halben Jahr intensiv damit beschäftigt
hat wobei ich das gut finde dass er das
macht ne ja aber ich will nur einfach
sagen das ist jetzt ein großes Thema
aber ich kenne mich damit nicht aus aber
ich könnte mir vorstellen dass in der
Giftküche der Mörder Waffen ja auch noch
viele andere schreckliche Dinge Lagern
nicht nur taktischer Atomwaffen
und wie kalkuliert man in der Situation
das Risiko da gibt es auf der einen
Seite die Stimmen die sagen ja wir
nehmen es ernst aber der wirft das höre
ich jetzt ganz oft ne das hat unlängst
Norbert Röttgen noch mal gesagt ja
Annalena baerbock also die sagen wir
nehmen das schon ernst ja aber letztlich
verlassen Sie sich darauf weil er
verblüfft weil er sich international
komplett isolieren würde weil er dann
auch die Chinesen verliert und und und
das alles ist plausibel aber leider
nicht sicher und da muss ich an dieses
kluge Buch von ganzem Taleb denken der
schwarze schwarz schwarze Schwan ja der
Einsatz von Atomwaffen wären nach Taleb
übrigens kein schwarzer Schwan also
schwarzer Schwan ich will das mal
erklären weil die haben uns doch schon
mal so schön überschwäne unterhalten und
uns mit der Frage beschäftigt ob man
schnell
genau
also Schwäne schmecken nach Kran ja und
Schwäne grün aktiv ja und ja ist alles
voller Salmonellen gründeln heißt die
nehmen die in sich auf ja so die gehen
mit dem Hals so tief runter und fressen
so vom vom motherboden okay gut ja das
heißt ich besonders gesund was da alles
so ist und da ist die Salmonellen Gefahr
hoch es gibt wohl Restaurants in
Norddeutschland die Schwanen anbieten
nicht viele aber Schwäne hat man nur aus
Prestige gegessen und nicht weil sie gut
schmecken und ungesund sollen sie auch
sein so der schwarze Schwan ist jetzt
folgende Geschichte das muss man
erzählen weil das ist spannend ja der
Römer Juvenal ja römischer Dichter der
hat was frauenfeindliches gesagt er hat
nämlich gesagt eine treue Ehefrau ist so
selten wie ein schwarzer Schwan
und schwarze Schwäne waren zum damaligen
Zeitpunkt nicht bekannt also nach dem
Motto die gibt es nicht alle Ehefrauen
sind Untreue die Frage wäre nur mit wem
sind sie untreuene die Frage hat er
natürlich nicht gestellt die hat er
nicht gestellt er hat auch keinen
tierischen gelegt für seine Theorie
gebracht und so weiter wir wollen auch
diese Theorie nicht größer machen als
sie ist behaupten dass die stimmt aber
das Interessante daran ist dass es immer
verbreitet war doch die Kirche hat doch
gesagt ne schwarze Schwäne gibt's nicht
ne gott hat die schöne weiß gemacht und
der Barock Theologie und dann entdeckt
man 1697 schwarzen Schwan in Australien
also europäische Entdecker in Australien
so und dann war die Reaktion darauf es
gab ja keine Fotos ja da war ja nicht
Markus Lanz und hat Bilder gemacht ja
und dann aus dem eigenen Expedition so
das hat man schlichtweg einfach mal so
80 Jahre alt
1780 das dann offiziell in einem
ornithologischen Lehrbuch von Herrn
lettem ich habe das Buch zu Hause
anerkannt wurde das ist tatsächlich
nicht so schwer gibt ist das ist das ein
Gendefekt oder was ist das nee es gibt
sieben schwanarten es gibt es gab auch
vorher das war schon vorher bekannt den
schwarz-wels Schwan der weiß ist aber
ein schwarzen Hals hat okay ja also da
danach hätte es gar nicht mehr so
unwahrscheinlich sein können dass in
anderen Erdteilen des schwarze Schwäne
gibt interessant ja und es ist auch kein
Zufall das ist Australien ist da gibt's
ja alles wie du weißt die Tierwelt halt
spät entdeckt worden und dadurch konnte
das eben passieren dass der Trauerschwan
wieder heißt dass er nicht ja aber die
Pointe bei Taleb sagt der schwarze
Schwan ist das völlig Undenkbare was
trotzdem eintritt
und er sagt immer wir überschätzen
Erfahrungen und Expertisen ja weil
Erfahrung und Expertisen geben keine
Sicherheit sondern eben nur
Wahrscheinlichkeiten aber in einer Welt
der Wahrscheinlichkeiten können auch
unwahrscheinliche Dinge eintreten er ist
dann bei Corona gefragt worden ob das
der schwarze Schwan wäre und da hat er
gesagt sie haben mich überhaupt nicht
verstanden dass eine Pandemie ausbricht
ist doch nicht völlig undenkbar
natürlich das sind grauerschwein ja
grauer Schwan ist ja was
unwahrscheinlich ist aber passieren kann
ja genau ja und und ich meine die
Situation in der wir uns im Augenblick
bewegen ja ist eine Situation ist ein
Teich voller grauer Schwäne
also lauter Dinge wo wir sagen na ja das
wird wahrscheinlich nicht passieren aber
es kann passieren
und ein nukleareinsatz ist eben kein
schwarzer Schwan ist nicht das völlig
Undenkbare was es für uns vielleicht
noch gewesen wäre vor einem Jahr ja
sondern das hat sich von einem schwarzen
Schwan in einen grauen Schwan verwandelt
und das ist schon mulmige Situation wo
wir einfach sagen wir können zwar sagen
es ist nicht wahrscheinlich
aber das ist wenig zu sagen ja ich ich
habe
hier einen Satz von fontale genau aus
diesem Buch ist wirklich ein großartiges
Buch ne der schwarze Schwanz
internationaler Bestseller über über
über Risiken und Wahrscheinlichkeiten
und wie man ein bisschen
Finanzmathematiker nicht also genau
Libanese soweit ich weiß und da steht
der Satz drin pass auf ist total
interessant auf die jetzige Situation
wir müssen den Extremfall als
Ausgangspunkt benutzen wir dürfen ihn
nicht als Ausnahme behandeln die man
unter den Teppich kehren kann so wo du
den schwarzen Schwan auf Dauer auch
nicht unter den Teppich kehren konntest
aber jetzt ist natürlich interessant
jetzt die Überlegung anstellen was ist
ja wenn tatsächlich Atomwaffen
eingesetzt werden
und wie reagiert man so darauf dass man
sagt das bleibt nicht ungestraft ohne
dass die nächste Eskalationsstufe und
das wäre dann der globale Atomkrieg
erreicht wird pass auf Bernd Ulrich sehr
kluger Autor der Zeit auch interessanter
Satz der sagt weil es nie wieder so sein
wird wie es war wird die Politik damit
aufhören müssen das gewohnte als ein
Anrecht zu behandeln und zwar einfach
nur deswegen weil sie dieses Recht nicht
mehr gewährleisten kann
Gedanke der übrigens direkt an den
vorhin von dir zitierten Ulrich Beck
anknüpft genau also Ulrich Beck ne
deutscher Soziologe vor leider zwei drei
Jahren gestorben ja oder vier Jahren
1986 zum genau richtigen Zeitpunkt
nämlich tschernoby parallel ohne das zu
wissen
erschien dieses Buch die
Risikogesellschaft und er eben gesagt
hat moderne Gesellschaften sind dadurch
charakterisiert dass die Risiken immer
größer werden immer globaler werden was
ist wenn Kernkraftwerk hochgeht
Atomkrieg ganze Welt wird vernichtet
eben nicht nur Konflikt zwischen zwei
Ländern globalen Umweltverschmutzung
dein nationaler Zaun hilft Dir nicht
mehr ne nationaler grenzzaunlich das
haben wir aber Tschernobyl gesehen ne
plötzlich war die Wolke da trotz
Eisernen Vorhangs und allem und hatte
dann sogar praktische Tipps naja was
macht eine Risikogesellschaft um die
Risiko zu kalkulieren er hat zum
Beispiel den damals denkwürdigen
Vorschlag gemacht Atomkraftwerke müssten
geändert werden so das ist ja völlig
klar wenn ich jetzt sage ich habe hier
ein Atomkraftwerk ja und ich frage jetzt
bei einer großen Versicherung an ob die
das versichern dann sagen Sie es können
wir natürlich nicht versichern weil wenn
es hoch geht komplett erledigt
so und dann hat er gesagt ja aber wenn
das Risiko einer Versicherung nicht zu
gutbar ist wie ist es dann der
Gesellschaft so gut war das war damals
sozusagen sein sein Kniff ja um zu sagen
ist ein Risiko tragbar oder ist ein
Risiko nicht tragbar
für Atomkraftwerke mag das nach wie vor
interessante Frage sein für die Frage
nach ermöglichen Atomschlag kann man mit
Versicherung natürlich auch nicht weiter
nicht weiter ich hatte ich hatte
diesbezüglich der ein oder andere Max
gesehen haben einen sehr interessanten
Moment hatten wir in der Sendung und
zwar da Christian Mölling der sich sehr
viel mit sicherheits- und
Verteidigungspolitik beschäftigt
klugermann der
sagt es war interessant ich habe ich
habe das Wort Atomschlag in die Runde
gegeben
und habe dann gesagt und dann haben wir
alle sofort dieses Bild vor Augen nur
der Atompilz steigt auf und und und und
wir wir sind am Ende ja und wer als
Erster schießt ist als zweiter Tod und
so weiter so all diese Dinge und er
guckte mich so an und sagte so Herr Lanz
jetzt spielen sie gerade Putins Spiel
dann habe ich zu ihm gesagt vielleicht
und zwar wenn das an der Stelle belassen
und was wir dann gemacht haben war
wollte er erst nicht so richtig aber war
mal wirklich reinzugehen in die
Szenarien
und was dann passiert ist war
interessant jeder der das hört hat
plötzlich eine Vorstellung davon und
dann wird die Angst dieses dieses
mulmige Gefühl vor dem Unbekannten wird
dann plötzlich kleiner wird neulich
Stefan Grünewald in der Sendung und der
der Chef vom Rheingold Instituten sehr
origineller Rheinländer der immer sehr
originell formuliert und der auf die
Frage wie man mit sowas umgehen sollte
psychologisch einfach nur sagte weißt du
das ist ein bisschen wie in so einem
Hitchcock Film ja solange sich nur so
der Duschvorhang bewegt ja und und du
den den Mörder der da rumschleicht nicht
siehst hast du wahnsinnige Angst aber in
dem Moment wo der Vampir sozusagen den
Raum betritt und du siehst wie dieser
Vampir aussieht und du weißt immer eine
Enttäuschung
aber verliert dann auch seinen Schrecken
und und darüber haben wir gesprochen und
es war interessant es gibt eigentlich so
drei Szenarien die da wirklich denkbar
sind das eine ist du zündest eine
sogenannte taktische Atomwaffe die nicht
so wahnsinnig stark ist einfach irgendwo
über dem Schwarzen Meer oder über der
Ostsee und da gibt es ein radioaktiven
Fallout und klar wenn dann der Wind
falsch weht dann hast du auch eine eine
Verseuchung irgendwo aber das ist
eigentlich eine Waffe die die die
zumindest oft am am Boden keine
katastrophale Wirkung hätte die aber
sagt pass auf Freunde wir sind bereit
über diese rote Linie zu gehen okay
bevor wir zum zweitens den haben wir
kommen hat er gesagt wie der Westen dann
darauf reagieren würde ja auch auch dazu
komme ich gleich das zweite Szenario
wäre eine taktische Atomwaffe deutlich
stärker
die du irgendwo über ukrainischem
Territorium zündest die dann
Hiroshima mal 10 15 ja das ist der
Faktor das ist so folgenden Effekt dann
zerstörst du sozusagen alle Satelliten
Navigationssysteme alle Dinge die dort
gerade wichtig sind einfach durch die
Strahlung was in diesem Krieg eine sehr
wichtige Rolle spielt Aufklärungsarbeit
ne die Amerikaner sagen den Ukrainern
sehr sehr genau wo die Stellungen der
Russen sind mehrere Millionen Menschen
so dünner
weil diese Strahlung keine Menschen
tötet nee weil diese Waffe nicht diese
Stärke hat und weil du sie in der Luft
zündest sehr weit und so es gäbe ein
radioaktiven Fallout und in der Folge
würden natürlich Menschen weil wir haben
Krebserkrankung und so weiter aber
unmittelbar tust du das nicht und es
gäbe die dritte Möglichkeit sozusagen
eine taktische Atombombe da reden wir
Radius ungefähr 100 150 km wo du dann
wirklich eine Stadt wie Mario Pool zum
Beispiel komplett dem Erdboden gleich
machst
und ich habe das Herrn Mölling so
dargelegt und Herr Mölling guckte mich
so an ist was interessant und sagte und
dann und das war natürlich eine total
gute Frage meine Frage genau weil er
sagte was was soll denn dann sein was
soll Putin mit einer vollkommen
radioaktiv verseuchten Stadt mit einer
völlig zerstörten was soll der damit
anfangen was ist das für ein
Kriegsgebiet in der dann hat und dann
hat er dargelegt das fand ich sehr
interessant er sagte auch die Angst
davor dass dann der Westen unmittelbar
selber mit Atomwaffen reagieren müsste
die teilt er so nicht unbedingt keine
andere Experten kann ja nicht dann auf
russische Territorium Atomwaffe die
machen weil dann haben wir das Worst
Case Szenario dann geht alles alles
kaputt genau aber auch deswegen weil die
Leute die sich damit auskennen sagen es
gibt auch sozusagen unter der atomaren
Schwelle mit konventionellen Waffen noch
unglaublich viele Stufen genau das was
ich vermute was als nächstes kommt aber
weißt du ist das was ich vorhin sagte
alles graue Schwäne
aber ich denke mal es gibt so viele
gruselig grausige Mörder Waffen ja und
auch im erweiterten konventionellen
Bereich
das
sind jetzt zum Teil
hellgraue Schwäne ja also also die
eingesetzt werden also keine Sachen wo
wir sagen das ist besonders
unwahrscheinlich sondern wo wir sagen
müssen das ist durchaus denkbar
also das alles ist ja Anlass so großer
mulmigkeit also meine mulmigkeit rührt
ja nicht daher dass ich jetzt denke der
nächste Schritt ist eine Rakete auf
Berlin sondern die Wohligkeit ist ja
schlimm genug wenn am Ende Millionen von
Ukrainern ja solch fürchterlichen Waffen
ausgesetzt werden das ist ja bereits ein
absolutes Horus Szenario selbst wenn wir
jetzt persönlich nicht betroffen sind es
ist für die Ukraine was grausigste und
grässlichste was sie sich gegenwärtig
vorstellen kann ja vielleicht sind es
auch 20.000 Menschen vielleicht sind es
10.000 Menschen vielleicht sind 100.000
Menschen der Krieg weitergeht dann
werden diese Waffen noch mehrfach
eingesetzt ja solange bis Putin seine
Kriegsziele erreicht das ist ja also der
der denkbare Horror ja und zwar der der
grauen Schwäne nicht der schwarzen
Schwäne der ist ja enorm
ja das stimmt wobei eben auch da wenn du
es hat ja lange Zeit gedauert bis
sozusagen starten ein kompliziertes und
lange verhandeltes Regelwerk darüber
hatten wie man mit genau diesen Waffen
umgeht und ich sagte ja vorhin
eigentlich muss man ja auch an der
Stelle mal konstatieren und dass ich
nicht alleine so auch Georg Mascolo hat
dieser Tag in der Eiszeit darüber
geschrieben fand ich interessant sagt da
gibt es plötzlich wieder diese atomare
Bedrohung die kommt jetzt mit Macht
zurück aber es lohnt sich daran zu
erinnern dass bei aller Zuspitzung die
große Auslöschung stets verhindert
worden ist das stimmt also wir haben
offensichtlich ein Regelwerk und
geschossen ist bisher so und deswegen
würde ich auch der Position immer sagen
es ist wahrscheinlicher das Putin keine
Nuklearwaffen einsetzt aber das Risiko
ist trotzdem da und man spricht ja nicht
aber man tut ja Putin dadurch keinen
gefallen dass man sagt wir nehmen die
Drogen ernst weil das sagt alle ne also
das ernst neben der Drohung da sind wir
uns glaube ich alle einig ich glaube
kaum jemand der sagt ach was das ist
sowieso noch läuft da brauchen wir uns
gar nicht weiter für interessieren alle
sagen es muss ernst genommen werden und
ich glaube hinter den Kulissen wird auch
die ganze Zeit über die Frage
nachgedacht ja was tun wir da genau ich
weiß auch nicht ob man da schon
irgendeine wirkliche Idee hat was man
oder im fertigen Plan was man dann tut
dass man sagt wenn er das macht machen
wir das und wenn er das macht machen wir
das
was ich ja wenn du wenn du wenn du mal
von der militärischen Nutzung von
Atomkraft ja schon diesen schrecklichen
Waffen weggehst der zivile Einsatz von
Atomkraft also die auch die Debatte um
Atomkraftwerke ist ja auch wieder zurück
ne total interessant auch was womit man
nicht gerechnet hätte noch für mich es
gibt es gibt es fand ich also 78% der
der deutschen ne haben sich in einer
Umfrage dafür ausgesprochen die drei
noch laufen in deutschen AKW bis zum
Sommer 2023 weiter zu betreiben das
konnte ich mir irgendwie vorstellen ich
konnte mir auch vorstellen dass knapp
70% sagen
mindestens für weitere fünf Jahre nur
27% nach dieser Umfrage haben das klar
abgelehnt aber was ich wirklich
interessant finde ist folgende
zahlreichert 41% der deutschen das ist
jetzt nicht wenig
befürworten sogar den Neubau von
Kernkraftwerken also ich ja die Zahl
kann ich nur einschätzen wenn ich mal
wüsste ob es Zahlen gibt als Angela
Merkel den Atomausstieg verkündet hat ja
wie waren damals die Umfragewerte dafür
unter dagegen also ich weiß gar nicht ob
man gut wenn man fukushi mal jetzt
sozusagen mal so die die unmittelbare
Zeit weglassen ja und mal sagen so wie
wie war die Lage vor Fukushima oder wie
war die
halbes Jahr später ich glaube dass der
Ausstieg aus der Atomenergie immer nur
schwach mehrheitsfähig war ich glaube
das ist immer relativ viele relativ
viele gehabt die gesagt haben im
Zeitalter des Klimawandels ist der
Kohleausstieg im Zweifel zwei wichtiger
als der domausstieg und das Balken
können wir gleich raus ich glaube das
haben viele so gesehen deswegen finde
ich jetzt diese 40 Prozent nicht so ganz
überraschend ich glaube die gab die Geld
gibt's schon lange
also ich du weißt dass die die Debatte
auch romatom und und noch Atomschlag und
so weiter die gibt es so fast nur in
Deutschland die gibt es nicht in
Frankreich die gibt es nicht in England
gibt es auch nicht in den USA die gibt
es vor allen Dingen bei uns und deswegen
sind wir da auch ein ein Ziel von
russischer Propaganda immer wieder wenn
es darum geht sozusagen an dem Punkt uns
zu verunsichern und und zu ängstigen und
so weiter aber diese zivile Nutzung des
das fand ich wirklich interessant wir
sind gestoßen in der Recherche auf Anna
Veronika Wendland kennst du die
Historikerin war lange lange Zeit eine
akw-gegnerin war viel zu
Forschungszwecken an AKW auch in der
Ukraine unterwegs und so weiter und hat
dann wegen des Klimawandels ihre Meinung
wirklich geändert setzt sich
mittlerweile für längere Laufzeiten ein
und wenn man dann mal den Blick weitet
in andere Länder dann siehst du dort
ähnliche Entwicklungen Frankreich und
Schweden erreichen ja eigentlich mit mit
einer Kombination aus Kernenergie und
erneuerbarer Energie eigentlich schon
heute die Klimaziele die wir erst
irgendwann erreichen
also die die Finnen bauen neue AKW und
so weiter also das ist da tut sich
gerade was finnische grüne sprechen sich
für Atomkraft auch ich kenne schwedische
grüne die sich für Atomkraft aussprechen
und so weiter das ist wirklich sehr sehr
spannend was da gerade passiert das ist
ja auch eine schwierige Situation also
wenn die dir jetzt und DIN A4 Zettel
dahin
und dann trägst du auf der einen Seite
ein was spricht für Atomkraft in die
nächsten Jahren und was spricht dagegen
dann findest du ja auf beiden Seiten
Argumente und du hast du Argumente die
ganz schwer miteinander abzuwägen sind
also du hast das Argument das Atomkraft
natürlich sauberer ist als Kohle Energie
unter klimagesichtspunkt da müssen wir
gar nicht drüber nachdenken
das ist natürlich ein Argument das
zweite Argument ist jetzt haben wir die
die große Krise ja da sind wir dringend
darauf angewiesen ansonsten kommen wir
in diesem Winter vielleicht den
Teufelsküche das wäre ein zweites
Argument zumindest für eine gewisse Zeit
das weiterlaufen zu lassen
auf der anderen Seite hast du das
natürlich nach wie vor ungeklärte
Probleme mit dem Atommüll gelehrt also
noch über eine Million Jahre radioaktiv
strahlt und wir immer noch keine richtig
gute Idee haben wie wir den mal lagern
und dem wir künftigen Generationen dann
vor die Füße werfen und wir haben in
einer Zeit wo der militärische Konflikt
da ist und wo wir immer damit rechnen
müssen dass fürchterliche Taten aus
Russland passieren können mit
Atomkraftwerken auch noch großartige
Ziele so und wie will man haben wir
wieder genau dasselbe wie kann man
sozusagen die Vorteile der Kernenergie
und die Risiken der Kernenergie
überhaupt vergleichen ich habe so das
Gefühl das ist so kompliziert ist ja
keine Waagschale wo man auf der einen
Seite Gewichte drauf tut und auf der
anderen Seite und dann hat man klares
Urteil genau solche werden Dinge
miteinander verglichen ja die alle mit
Unsicherheiten und Unklarheiten belastet
also die Vorteile der Kernenergie die
sind ganz einfach und klar aber auf der
anderen Seite die Risiken der
Kernenergie die sind in der
atommüllfrage klar aber die sind zum
Beispiel in der kriegszielfrage völlig
unklar
und das macht so eine Abwägung
unglaublich schwierig ich weiß nicht wie
es Dir geht da hast du das in deinem
Kopf leicht deine Abwägung vorzunehmen
ja kann ich dir sagen ich ich habe
dieser Tage was total interessantes
gelesen Atomkraft hat ungefähr dieselbe
CO2-Bilanz wie Windkraft
ja und da habe ich immer gedacht ja dann
doch Windkraft und dann habe ich noch
eine zweite Sache gelesen nämlich das
Atomkraft ist ja sehr sehr teuer und
ausgerechnet die Amerikaner die nie im
Verdacht standen speziell unter Trump
sehr auf die Erneuerbaren zu setzen mit
Ausnahme Kalifornien und so weiter
und ich hatte immer das Gefühl die
setzen voll auch auf diese
Risikotechnologie die schalten sechs
Atomkraftwerke ab in diesem Jahr und
weißt du warum jetzt kommt der Clou weil
Solar und Wind billiger ist
und deswegen ist das aber das ist ja der
Gedanke nicht wir reden ja nicht
ernsthaft darüber neue Atomkraftwerke zu
bauen das ist ja auch im Augenblick
nicht tatsächlich das verhandlungs Thema
du weltweit werden viele ich weiß aber
in Deutschland braucht in Deutschland
mag es 40% Zustimmung geben aber die
werden nicht gebaut sondern wir treten
wir ja darüber ob wir ob wir zwei oder
drei Atomkraftwerke 23 Jahre länger
laufen lassen also das ist ja das
worüber wir im Augenblick nachdenken
also wir denken ja nicht darüber nach
den Ausstieg aus der Atomenergie
rückgängig zu machen sondern wir denken
darüber nach ihn ein klein bisschen
langsamer zu machen
die
Amerikaner gehen weg von der Atomkraft
die Franzosen setzen unglaublich auf
Atomkraft
da ist keine Logik reinzukriegen
also die Atomkraftwerke der Franzosen
sind unglaublich defiziert um Strom ist
wahnsinnig teuer und das kommt das Thema
dass du natürlich du musst die kühlen
und die heißer die Sommer werden und je
niedriger die Pegelstände in den Flüssen
werden desto größere Probleme hast du
diese diese Kraftwerke zu kühlen Richard
noch mal Ulrich Beck ich habe mich in
Vorbereitung auf unser Gespräch heute
ein bisschen mit Ulrich Beck noch mal
beschäftigt ne der berühmte Münchner
Soziologe zum Schluss
Risikogesellschaft das war ja damals ein
weltweiterhof economics ja genau und ein
weltweiter Bestseller
weil er damals natürlich im sozusagen
mit Blick auf Tschernobyl wirklich einen
absoluten Kern getroffen hat
und der sagt etwas sehr Interessantes
der unterscheidet in diesem Buch
zwischen Gefahr und Risiko
und sagt Gefahr
das was wieder gerade besprochen haben
es könnte man ja abtun unter Gefahr
könnte sagen ja gut da gibt es eine
Gefahr und dann müssen wir irgendwie
entscheiden ob wir diese Gefahr
einschätzen können und wie wir damit
umgehen aber er sagt Gefahr ist was
anderes Gefahr ist in der
Naturkatastrophe Gefahr ist wenn es
plötzlich unvorstellbar regnet oder bei
uns in den Bergen so viel Schnee vom
Himmel fällt das plötzlich die Lawine
kommt damit musst du immer rechnen das
ist Gefahr da kannst du auch nichts
dagegen tun aber Risiko und das ist das
eigentliche Thema hier beim Thema
Kernkraft und auch anderen Dingen auch
bei der Frage wie gehen wir in der
Ukraine weiter vor
Risikos etwas in das wir selber aktiv
eingreifen und sagen was davon sind wir
bereit zu übernehmen was davon das
Risiko müssen wir müssen wir anders
kalkulieren also man kann ja sagen über
die größte Zahl der Mensch Teile der
Menschheitsgeschichte war das Leben viel
gefährlicher als es heute in Deutschland
ist so sehr sehr viel gefährlich es war
noch in der Generation in unserer
Generation gefährlicher als in der
Generation unsere Kinder ja also
Fahrradfahren ohne Sturzhelm und da gibt
es ja so eine bekannte Liste was alles
ne Betten die mit bleihaltigen Farben
angemalt waren und so weiter und und
keine Handys keine Handys man wusste
nicht wo die Kinder sind ja sie haben zu
Hause kommen also das war das war eine
Welt in früher waren die Gefahren größer
früher waren wir den den Gefahren der
Natur ja überall ausgesetzt nicht nur in
den Bergen gehen Gefahren von von
Kriegen ausgesetzt von von von
schrecklichen Pandemien die schlimmer
waren als das was wir mit Corona erleben
also Cholera Pest und so weiter
aber alle diese Dinge die hat man ja
nicht da hat man die Bedingungen nicht
für selber geschaffen und das ist eben
der Unterschied beim Risiko im Risiko
mache ich mit Absicht etwas und muss
einkalkulieren ob ich das für
vertretbare oder nicht genau und das ist
natürlich hier weiter die Technik
fortgeschritten ist umso größer werden
die Risiken also ich überlege in den
letzten Jahren haben wir so viel über
die Risiken künstlicher Intelligenz
debattiert ja also von Menschen die
Angst hatten dass Roboter sich
irgendwann gegen die Menschheit richten
so ist zu sagen weil sie der größte
Apokalypse ja das wäre eher der schwarze
Schwan bis hin zu den Sachen der
Schwarzenegger ist das ja aber ein
bisschen am Ende zwischen bis Ende zum
der Schwarzenegger Schwarm
ja bisschen zu zu den realistischeren
Szenario zum Beispiel eines ultimativen
Börsencrash ausgelöst durch künstliche
Intelligenz oder Systeme die nicht die
nicht mehr kontrollierbar sind nicht
weil sie böse sind sondern wenn sie
nicht mehr versteht oder nicht mehr
eindämmen kann also dass ich glaube das
Eindrucks Beispiel dafür hat ihnen Maske
mal erfunden er hat sich hat sich
überlegt was ist wenn eine künstliche
Intelligenz darauf programmiert wird
Erdbeerfelder anzulegen also ganz ganz
realistische Sachen ja so und das macht
die und das macht die immer weiter und
immer weiter und die ist also quasi nur
mit diesem Programm alles in
Erdbeerfelder zu verwandeln ist die
ausgestattet und die Geräte jetzt
insofern außer Kontrolle als dass man da
nichts mehr gegen tun kann ja dann würde
diese diese Roboter die würden nicht
rasten noch ruhen bis die ganze Welt in
ein einziges Erdbeerfeld verwandelt ist
strawberry fields forever ja und das
sind so diese dieses Szenarien es gibt
ein anderes anderes Beispiel was Nick
bosstrom bringt da geht es eben um
Büroklammern ja bis alles auf der Welt
zu Büroklammern verarbeitet ist also
dieses Szenarien und das sind das sind
eher so so
dunkelgraue Schwäne ja also eher so
Sachen wo man sagen kann das ist jetzt
nicht naheliegend aber es ist nicht gut
Nachteile muss man das Annehmen
genau richtig genau so das sind ja alles
Sachen die in der in der
hochtechnisierten Gesellschaft sind oder
die Gefahr des Missbrauchs ja wir können
mit Gesichtserkennung Software oder wenn
all die Daten in die Hände von
irgendwelchen James Bond Verbrechern
geraten oder in verbrecherischen Regimen
zur Verfügung steht was kann da nicht
alles ausgelöst werden in der Welt das
sind ja wie gesagt nicht mal schwarze
Schwäne sondern Dinge die man
einkalkulieren muss die man dem Moment
wo man diese Technik macht und anwendet
schon überlegen muss wie schützt man
sich davor und es ist klar je weiter die
technische Entwicklung geht um so
extremer wird die Risiko Gesellschaft
richtig sind interessant ne weißt du zum
Schluss ein tröstlicher Gedanke das sagt
Beck irgendwo in einem in einem
Interview vielleicht total interessant
Risiko die Frage sozusagen welches
Risiko du bereit bist zu gehen und auch
was du als riskant empfindest oder auch
als Gefahr empfindest ist natürlich auch
eine Kultur
er bringt das Beispiel eines eines armen
Afrikaners der von morgens bis abends
damit beschäftigt ist irgendwie Essen
aufzutreiben für seine Familie sagt der
lacht über diese Art von Angst die wir
uns häufig machen lassen wer Risiko der
Kernenergie ausgestiegener Fukushima die
Deutschen nicht die Japaner ja ja
aber aber die die Kernenergie hat ein so
positiven Status in Japan das nicht mal
diese enorme Katastrophe daran etwas
geändert hat
also kulturellen Prägung spielen eine
große Rolle und die zweite große Rolle
wie du gerade sagst die Lebensumstände
wenn ich nicht weiß was ich morgen zu
essen habe ja ist Atomkrieg nicht das
was mir schlaflose Nächte macht so dass
der Punkt und ein letzter Gedanke noch
dazu hat habe ich mich neulich mit
jemandem darüber unterhalten aus aus dem
politischen Journalismus will es keine
Namen nennen oder sagt etwas total
interessant ist so Frage es gibt ja
diesen diesen diesen Mythos ja angela
Merkel ist so überhastet aus dem aus der
Atomkraft ausgestiegen weil sie
eigentlich Angst hatte davor eine Wahl
in Baden-Württemberg zu verlieren ja
Stefan Mappus ist das Stichwort hat dann
trotz vorstellen hat dann trotzdem die
Wahl verloren na ja das da gab es schon
einen ich sag mal so das war zeitlich so
nah dran man könnte den Verdacht haben
und wenn ich gerade mitkriege was alles
gemacht und vor allen Dingen nicht
gemacht wird oder zu heiligen Kuh
erklärt wird
mit Blick auf diese niedersachsenwahl
das ist atemberaubend das hält man nicht
für möglich wie gesagt
sich die Politik in einem dramatischen
Ausmaß genau das ist aber so aber pass
auf jetzt kommt mein Argument der sagte
folgendes er sagte nee
merkel war sich darüber im Klaren dass
das der Vorwurf ist und vielleicht war
da auch ein bisschen was dran ja man sie
wusste um die Angst der Deutschen vor
atommerergie und so weiter aber sie
sagte etwas anderes und das finde ich
ein extrem gutes stichhaltiges Argument
sie sagte
für mich war klar in dem Moment wenn
eine so zivilisierte Nation also
technologisch weit entwickelte Nation
wie die Japaner die diese hohe
Ingenieurskunst haben die so viel davon
verstehen von Technik wie vielleicht
niemand anderer auf der Welt weil sie
Technik wirklich durchdringen und
Technik im Alltag eine so große Rolle
spielt wenn nicht mal die in der Lage
sind diese
Atomenergie zu beherrschen diese Art von
Energie zu beherrschen dann sollten wir
nicht so überheblich sein zu glauben
dass wir es auch können
das fand ich ein gutes Argument da ist
eine Menge dran
da ist eine große Menge dran vielleicht
hilft ja doch der backvorschlag mit den
Versicherungen
was wir sagen wir lassen wir machen ein
Kompromiss ja wir verlängern die
Laufzeit jetzt von zwei Atomkraftwerken
unter der Bedingung dass wir einen
Versicherer dafür finden
okay dann hätten wir den richtigen
Kompromiss geschaffen ja so ist es also
Richard das war sehr inspirierend dankte
sehr ja ich denke ich dir Markus gutes
schreiben weiterhin ja ich werde
weiterhin über Macht und Ohnmacht
nachdenken also bis nächste Woche ja
Tschüss Markus viel Spaß
danke danke
eine Produktion von m hoch 2 und potsdas
bei OMR im Auftrag des ZDF
[Musik]